i mean yesterday i tell you a little
story boys okay yeah
it's it's kind of story time connoisseur
we're getting a graphic card story time
i went to the dmv gather around the
campfire oh my god
this is already sounding this is not a
campfire story it's already so i'm sorry
so
as you guys know none of us have the
ability to drive in japan but we all
have the licenses in our own respective
country
yes yes and i thought well one of us
needs to do it i'll do it i like driving
gone hates driving
and joey's just joey so joey just stands
there being like i don't want to help me
yeah joey doesn't want to spend a whole
day at a dmv
and more probably yeah from my my
relationship with driving
is that it's it's it literally serves a
purpose like i don't care i if it gets
if i can get from point a to point b in
a way that's like other than driving or
someone else can drive me
i don't care if i have to drive i'll
[ __ ] do it but i can afford an uber
i'm convinced that you wanted to become
a rich person just to get a chauffeur
that's like eventually that's a dream
dude that's the dream i i okay like okay
i don't hate driving what i hate
is parking my god like i
i just like at all the thought of
parking yes because i suck at parking
okay
i barely passed my test when it came to
like parallel parking
the thought of parallel parking gives me
nightmares like i wake up in a cold
sweat and i'm like
what if the car doesn't fit and i'm
making a fool of myself like
spending 10 minutes trying to get into
this slot because everyone's been on the
other end right where you're trying to
watch someone parallel park and they're
just like come on it's not that hard and
then when you actually go to do it's
like
oh it's that hard i somehow nail like
the hard parking and then
take 15 attempts for the shittiest
easiest parking
when there's like 100 people around me
just watching me like really
embarrassing
yeah but yeah i wanted to get my license
because you know i wanted to
have the options open because i feel
like you can still explore a lot of
japan without a car yeah it's just
some places you know that once you're
outside of tokyo you pretty much need a
car yeah becomes a little more difficult
especially if you
want to really explore a lot like if you
want to stick to the main tourist stuff
there's there's buses and stuff
you'll be fine but i wanted to drive and
i mean nothing goes better with my beep
boop daft punk music than driving
like one i love driving with music man
it's so like just smacking that wheel
you know
you're like a [ __ ] you're like a dad
yeah man i love it i love all of it so i
thought you know what i'm gonna
get my license because if you have a
british license in japan and a select
few of the countries a lot of european
ones
they said like america but only hawaii
and alaska it was like
so only hawaii and alaska can do it if
you're from any of the countries where
you don't
from those countries you have to do a
test hawaiian alaska i have no idea it
was i don't think it was hawaiian alaska
it was alaska and some other country
i have something to say which is really
confusing because i'm pretty sure don't
they all drive on the same side of the
road yeah i thought so
right because the reason why something
we don't know because the reason why
americans have to do a driving test is
because
we drive on the other side of the road
right does alaska drive on the same side
of the road
japan let us know yes so i had to go to
the dmv and i knew it was going to be a
stressful process because it always is
with any driving
i mean that's just universal but yeah i
can only imagine how stressful it is
in japan because the extra layers you
have to do right
right right because you're like it was
already hell in my own country
yeah it's probably gonna be hell again
in in japan
yeah times two and i had to bring a
translator with me yeah uh so it was
just
so glad the translator was not me i was
gonna ask joey
but then another friend offered and i'm
like but then i was like oh you're in
the dmv
sorry i'm busy i'm busy that day i got
caught i'm not bad man
so first i'm going to ask how long were
you there for i got there at 8
20 in the morning right why so early so
to line up
yes so right now because i
i'm not sure if it's because of
curvature but right now only 10 people
are allowed to get a foreign license a
day in the whole one
so it's like first come first serve yes
so whoever's at first gets it if you
don't you have to
come back at 2 30 and wait but they give
out the 2 30 slots
in that at 9am so i was in the 230 slot
oh [ __ ]
so i got this i queued up at 8 20. i was
told
on the website it says 9 30. get there
at 9 30. yeah and then i
i called them up and i asked hey what
time should i get there they said get
there for like uh eight
eight so i got that 8 20 because i
thought oh it's no one's gonna be there
yeah there was already like
14 people lined up when i got there and
so i was in the second bunch
um so they only give out 10 licenses a
day
in the whole prefecture which is like
millions of people
yeah for foreigners and it's like what
how is this a thing why only ten
like they just do the first ten like go
home at least it wasn't like the
[ __ ] like you know
you know you know when they did like
event gotchas and stuff right right
here's a ticket and if you win the
ticket you have a chance to wow
well we'll see what i'll tell you more
about the store okay
so it's like an hour away from me so i
have to get up at like
6 a.m which is way over my like comfort
zone yeah i can wake up at eight
and be like anything before 7 30. i feel
like [ __ ] the whole day
exactly so i get there and we line up
and then i have to wait an hour to get
my
ticket so i have to wait an hour to wait
more
so i then i went to coco's diner which
is like coco hannity yeah
went there stayed there for three and a
half hours jesus christ came back to the
place
waited another hour finally got to go in
as i'm going in this couple is like
screaming at the employees right like
what the [ __ ] or something in japanese i
remember
some of it from anime so yeah they were
saying the bad anime words yeah
and i was like i was like that's a nabi
i was like what happened he's like
apparently he didn't have the right
documents right but before we went in
they gathered us all around and were
like hey
uh some of you are going to be rejected
today for no reason
um they literally said that they said
what they said we might reject you
and not explain why and i'm like what
what is this youtube demonetization what
do you mean i've come here all day
and you have to bring like so many
[ __ ] documents you have to get like
your license translated at a different
building yeah wait a few days for that
go to the the ward office which is
another building get proof that you live
where you say you live yeah bring your
other license your passport
literally every single documentation
that you were ever a person to begin
with yeah
and uh yeah and then they they grilled
me for like an hour
like asking me asking asking what well
they so
apart of to get the foreign license you
have to prove that you were in the
country where you got your license
uh for six months yeah yeah after the
fact so
i brought tons of paperwork proving that
i was in the uk at the time when i got
it for six months
and they just kept grilling me and
asking me pointless questions what i
thought right like they asked like did
you have like
a provisional license which in the uk
and i think in america as well australia
too yeah yeah yeah you got a license
before the actual license yeah like did
you have one i'm like
obviously i had one i had to drive yeah
i'm thinking like i think yeah who
doesn't
what are you doing that's part of the
official process
i don't think a lot of countries would
let you get the full thing without doing
it
and i said i'll i'll speak about
thailand
so i'm like yeah of course i had that
and then they're like how long did it
take you to get your license
what do you mean how long ago did it
take like a week or did you do lessons
over a long time i was like it lasted
over a long time
then they're like oh did you how long
did you have the provisionals for i'm
like why you ask who cares
who cares who cares he's got you got the
full license yeah i'm like i'm like i
had it for five years and she's like
and then she asked why did you have it
for so long and i'm like
why does it matter how long because in
the uk we don't have id
we don't carry around id yeah so most
people get the provisional license even
if they don't intend yeah
yeah so i'm i'm here explaining like a
cultural difference to her
i'm like so so what did you say i
explained that i'm like in the uk we
don't really have id so people get the
idea but that's what
that's what japanese people do as well
yeah there's a lot of like what we call
being grilled for this thing in japan a
lot of people are like known as paper
drivers
which means they have the license but
they don't have it to drive they just
have it as a form of id yeah yeah
in in in the uk people get provisional
licenses because
we we use licenses to prove that we can
get into bars and parts yeah yeah that's
pretty much the only reason
we get provisional licenses yeah so i
had to wait an hour and i was like cool
i'm i'm
it's all going well she seems to be you
know happy with it she's like yeah
okay uh yeah no problem uh just come
back in two days i'm like what
what do you mean come back in two days
wait you didn't even get it i didn't get
it today
oh my god so you haven't got it yet no
after waiting how long did you how long
did you wait i left at 4pm and i got
there at 8am
and it's an hour away from eight hours
yeah like eight hours you wasted a whole
year i lost a whole day
to not getting a license to get the
paperwork
to get the license because i remember
you telling me just before
that you were getting this it's all a
bunch of fetch quests this is why they
love
[ __ ] this is why all the rpgs in
japan have a bazillion fetch quest
because living here is a [ __ ] fetch
quest
every time you want to do anything it's
like okay get the prerequisite items
which you
they're all in different locations
because of course they are like they're
not all in the government building
because that would be too easy yeah that
would make life too that's why gacha
games work here because you even have
the waiting time like the loading time
where
you you like think you got all the items
and then you have to like put it in to
like [ __ ] yeah you got it you got to
craft the item yeah and you got to wait
until the item is finished being crafted
and then you pull the dud gotcha
because you have to wait till 2 30. yeah
so they they said i have to come back on
wednesday which is tomorrow so i'm going
there tomorrow all right to do the eye
test
that's it i do the eye test and once i
prove i'm not [ __ ] blind
i get my license imagine if they just
reject you after this i would i would
[ __ ]
lose so you basically spend eight hours
for someone to tell you come back in two
days yeah
basically i i know that dmv is bad in
all countries but in the uk
i i would never have it that wasn't that
bad and especially with how many
documents you needed to grab before
just to get your license like just be
given a license as well
because it's crazy because like nabi who
went with you who's a friend of the
house yeah like when he went
he had such an easy time but i guess
it's because he got it before covent
i think i think they've made it a lot
slower yeah
from kovid like apparently and they also
told me that
if for some reason because of kobe the
amount of people applying has gone up a
lot well yeah
because no one can travel outside of the
country so therefore they'll want to
travel inside yeah
true but i guess i would have thought
the other way around but yeah that's
just
speaking to you has made me like has t
entirely put me off
from wanting to get a japanese license
now i'm glad at least someone on trash
takes now has a license because we're
just going to ask you to show for us
everywhere